I need your help as you probably notice
there's been a rise in the number of
scammers here on YouTube and off YouTube
but most importantly in the comments
down below if you haven't seen it
already it looks like this what people
will do is they'll take my icon and user
name and use an army of either BOTS or
other people with no lives and signal
boost that message to die to get you
guys to click that link do not click
links from here on out and I don't think
I've ever done it before I will never
put a link in the comments section under
my name I will not do it if I have a
link that you need to click it'll be in
the description of the video because
only I can put it there but if you ever
see someone with my icon in my username
posting a link saying there's a free
giveaway or free points or free anything
or it's an appreciation thing do not
click it it is spam it is a scam and
they will try to steal your information
and this is also happening off of
YouTube - there are other places like
new websites that are cropping up new
social media stuff that people will
steal my username and my icon I am NOT
on those sites the only sex that I'm on
our Twitter Facebook and Instagram as
well as vine sometimes but not all that
often and it's always under the names
that are listed in the description right
here so unless you see anything other
from me directly in the video please for
your own safety do not click a link do
not let your information get stolen do
not let your money get jeopardized
please stay safe out there so you can
help out by spreading the word reporting
these scammers and making sure that
everyone in the community stays as safe
as possible
they can only win if people actually
believe them so hopefully with this
message this will alleviate a lot of
pain and hopefully people will not get
scammed anymore stay safe guys alright
now with that out of the way we can move
on to the important business yes I
shaved I dropped ten years in one day
how did I do it doctors hate me I'm a
gym yes I shaved and I shaved because I
had a dream that I was shaving and I was
cutting up my face and I was bleeding
all over the place so I woke up and I
went oh I need to shave so I shaved now
I don't know if I'm gonna keep it shaved
I'm probably gonna grow scruff again
because I think it'd look pretty good
with scruff but hey not bad looking like
a prepubescent teen also we just
finished up the charity
live stream for May it was a great
success and in the last time I checked I
think we sold the five thousand two
hundred some-odd shirts for charity and
at fourteen dollars donated to the
make-a-wish Foundation for every shirt
sold
that's over seventy thousand dollars
raised for charity thank you guys so
much who supported that thank you
everyone who's there for it and if you
missed it you can watch it right now
there's seven and a half hours but
people have been posting timestamps now
don't click links be sure what you're
clicking but people have been posting
timestamps that's number : number number
leading to the time in the video or you
can just go to that time directly if you
don't feel like clicking on anything
just in case you want to stay as safe as
possible
but people have been guiding people to
the funniest moments in that livestream
because that was amazing
I love that livestream I've never
laughed harder in a livestream well
actually no I probably have laughed
harder but it reminded me way back when
when we were doing live streams back in
Cincinnati at my mom's house just having
a blast having these live streams and
just doing so many cool things for
charity and not that it's not a good one
I do it by myself but it's always so
much more fun to do with other people
and having Wade and Tyler here for this
past week has just been an incredible
experience because you know I miss them
dearly and people like you know get on
my case like oh why you so mean to wade
in Tyler why can't you be off not a sore
loser I'm like that's how we that's how
we do when I win I gloat when I lose I
am I mean and it's vice versa like
that's the friendship that we have it
and I'm and it's so cool that like I'm
able to do that on camera for you guys
like that's my greatest pleasure in life
the fact that I can do this stuff and
just enjoy it as much as possible and
bring other people joy all while doing
these things trying to lead you guys to
a better cause and that's what's really
important and if you missed it we raise
money for the make-a-wish Foundation but
I'm also doing two wishes people
actually are these children who are in
hospitals and they've been in hospitals
and I don't know the situation I don't
know the specifics of it but they
requested that I come visit them and do
a video with them and I said yes
absolutely I'll do whatever it takes so
sometime in June I'm going to be doing
two wishes for the make-a-wish
Foundation and I'll definitely put a
vlog Xand take pictures when I'm there
I was just I was so humbled by it
because you know III I often look back
and I see my old videos and I'm I'm
reminded of exactly where I was in time
when it happened and I'm reminded of why
I was doing it or what I did during that
specific video and because YouTube is
such a perfect catalog of every moment
of my life I can go back and I can
remember every single day of the past
three years of my life and it's pretty
incredible and I shaved so like I look
even more like I did when I started the
channel but it's astonishing to see
because I started this channel out with
the hope that I could do something that
I love to do and I never imagined that
it would lead to something where I could
actually like it help you guys change
the world because it's not me that's
actually doing anything I always try to
reiterate it's not actually me that's
doing the change I'm not making things
happen out I'm just trying to lead you
guys towards a better goal and and
trying to make the world a better place
and you guys have taken that to heart
and I so I'm so proud of you guys for
doing that I've said that before but
I'll say it again like thank you guys so
much for taking these causes to heart
and believing in what I do and the silly
antics of me and my friends do and it's
such a joy to be able to do this and
also know that the community that I
build over these years has taken these
causes to heart and is wanting to do
that and wanting to spread joy in the
world and that's why it's so important I
want to make sure that this community is
safe because I want you guys to have a
place that's your own in the world you
know this this channel is more yours
than it is mine like I do these things
to try to entertain you but you guys
have built it into something bigger and
that's because you guys reach out to
each other and you reach out to new
people every day and spread the word and
inspire others just by doing like you
may not think that you're doing much
just by being here and enjoying the
videos and if you just want to watch the
videos that's totally fine I understand
but this community is always going to be
more than that and I appreciate the fact
that you take that to heart I really
really do I love you guys for it and I
love everything that you've done to make
this happen and god damn I'm gonna miss
my friends like it sucks that I'm all
the way out here in LA and I've made
quite a few friends out here too like
I'm not saying I'm lonely by any stretch
of the imagination but man I miss I miss
hanging out with those guys because I
was a fun week that was a really fun
week that you still haven't seen all the
stuff that we've done during that week
but man over the next few weeks I'm
gonna be editing videos and it's gonna
be a great time these moments are
fleeting you know the time is short the
world is always changing those are all
cliches but it all comes down to that
you know the fact that I look back on
everything that I've done and I know
with absolute certainty I know that I
can be proud of what we've done here and
I know that I can be proud of what you
guys have done and I hope I really do
hope that I've influenced some people to
pursue what they wanted to do because I
I say it all the time and I know I drill
it into your heads but I really really
mean it and I want to get you guys up
and out there and doing something
amazing because I know there's so many
creative artists writers geniuses
mathematicians silly people like me
there's a ton of you guys out there with
so much potential and I want you guys to
be able to do whatever you want to do
because it takes that first step that's
all it is it literally is all it is take
that first step even if you have no idea
what you're gonna do why you're gonna do
it even if you have no idea what you
really want to do in life even if you
think you know and then you change your
mind that's fine I jumped from like 13
different subjects before I landed on
doing let's play videos and let's play
wasn't even what I really wanted to do
but now I'm so happy that I tried and
I'm so happy I went through like the
hardship going to the point and I'm so
happy I stuck with it even when I wanted
to give up and I'm so happy that I did
because it led to now where I can be in
front of you guys and I can be a big
emotional silly doof and I can tell you
guys that you matter and you really do
and every single one of you does
and I and I know I keep saying it over
and over again but I'm really proud of
what you guys have done so far because
even in the future no one knows what's
gonna happen five ten years from now
knowing like YouTube may not be here you
guys might find someone else to watch
her you guys might have grown up and
grown out of this silly phase but it
doesn't matter and I'm totally fine if
you do but just know that no one knows
what the future holds so you got to
start making it today you know you got
to start trying today and you have to
start going forward it's never too late
no matter how young no matter how old
you are
you can do it coz I believe in you and
not just me anymore you know everyone in
this community every single member of
this community whether you like it or
not you're part of this family you're
part of this and I'm so proud that you
are here and I'm not gay I'm gonna keep
rambling for hours and hours if I don't
stop it there but I just thank you guys
so much for watching thank you so much
for supporting hopefully next time Bob
can come out here because he's busy with
law school or whatever with real stuff
that he's doing and not silly doofy
funny faces and laughing on YouTube but
trust me when he gets out here there's
gonna be a lot of laughing a lot of
silly faces so thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you Wade Tyler
and Molly for being out here thank you
everyone who supported all of us so far
there's gonna be a lot of cool stuff to
see in the future so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye-bye
ah